Alen Harikian is the owner
of Speers TV,
a South-Pasadena
electronics store
that's been operating
in the neighborhood
for over 60 years.
But ever since a massive
Best Buy moved in
just minutes away
from his tiny shop,
he's been finding it impossible
to keep up with their
aggressive pricing.
- Their sales are ridiculous.
I mean, there's no way
that I can compete.
- And if it keeps up,
Speers TV is at risk
of going extinct.
So I paid Alen a visit
with an ambitious solution
to undercut
his biggest competitor.
Are you familiar with
the Best Buy price-match policy?
- Yeah. It's horrible.
I mean, it's bad
for small business.
- One of the main reasons
Alen has such a hard time
competing with Best Buy
is because of their aggressive
price-match policy,
which guarantees
they will match the price
of any local competitor,
preventing stores like Speers
from underselling them,
but if Alen
dropped his prices so low
to make his TVs virtually free,
according to Best Buy's
own policy,
they would have to match
that price, too,
giving Alen
a short window of time
where he could buy up
all their inventory for $1
and then resell those TVs
for any price he wants
to make a huge profit.
The plan: use Best Buy's
price-match policy against them
to get Speers an endless supply
of $1 TVs.
- Um...
It's a great idea.
- It might take a little bit
of work and time to do.
- Okay.
- Do you have a lot
going on right now?
- No, I honestly don't. No.
- So you don't
have commitments at home
or anything right now?
Relationship stuff?
- I'm not in a relationship, no.
- I'm not in a relationship
either, so...
- Oh.
- We can both work on this,
you know, full-time.
- Okay. All right. That's fine.
- After a bit more discussion,
Alen was on board to move
forward with dropping the price
on one of his premium
Samsung HD TV models
to just $1 apiece,
but once the new discounted
price went into effect,
people would be flocking
to Speers to get the deal.
So to help dissuade
these bargain hunters
from buying up
all of Alen's dollar TVs,
I implemented a strict
dress code, requiring customers
to wear formal attire
just to enter the store.
I then had all the dollar TVs
moved to an area
at the back of the store
and had a new wall constructed
to surround this area
that could only be entered
through a tiny,
two-foot-tall door.
Finally, in between the door
and the TVs,
I added a live alligator,
which would hopefully force
customers who made it this far
to reconsider their decision
to take advantage
of the great offer.